the Deep State's a deep State because
they run deep like you don't think
they're going to figure out a way they
have to stop they're they're probably
going crazy because this was such a
successful thing once it came on after
the glitch because once you know in the
future these glitches aren't going to
happen because journalism is dead if you
ask me it's just it's up to you to find
the truth this is just the truth you're
just hearing the person raw like we're
getting real-time information that's not
censored it's not biased it's not Fox
it's not CNN Elon mentioned that during
the Twitter spaces that this is the
future instead of doing Town squares
where a few people in your town can go
and sit down and talk to the candidate
now anybody on the globe